hey guys dr. Burks here we're going to
talk about the biggest mistake people
make doing the ketosis diet okay
basically consuming too much fat if you
look up the ketosis diet they say that
you can have 85% of your calories of fat
right that is a lot of fat if you were
to consume 2,500 calories from fat that
comes out to 220 grams of fat that is
way too much so what will happen is
you're going to be burning on that fat
and not tapping into your own fat you'll
be in ketosis but you won't lose anyway
okay so I suggest you reduce it down
about 60% of calories but it's kind of
like you have to go slow with the fat
the fat is the big variable that you
want to kind of gradually increase
because a lot of people can't digest fat
so you have to get used to you have to
build up your enzymes so this whole idea
of like just dumping all this butter or
coconut oil in your coffee and just
start plugging all these keto bombs into
the the meals not actually a good thing
well if for some people they can do it
other people they can so ketosis in
general suppresses your appetite so
what's going to happen is you're going
to get you're not going to be hungry
hardly at all anymore you're going to be
able to go many many hours without
eating so you want to let let the hunger
dictate how much fat you eat after you
get in ketosis you can back off some of
the fat and not have so much and then
you can actually start living off your
own reserves your own fat in your belly
and the rest of the body but there are
people that just overdo it
especially like the keto Bob's they'll
just eat a whole plate and I actually
have a lot of videos on how to make them
so the whole goal is just to have like
one okay but I would just if you're not
hungry cut down on the fat and go a
little bit lighter it's really each meal
you have to judge how much you need you
might need a little bit more but don't
go crazy okay because that's going to
slow you down all right thanks for
watching
hey guys thank you so much for watching
please click the subscribe button and I
will see you in the next video